we are here in Warsaw with mikoi who is
also a big chess fan he came today for
rabbit and Blitz super bet tournament so
how are you doing here do you like to be
here uh yeah I do so far I got the
signature from Wesley saw and now I'm
waiting for the second round to finish
to hope to get some more yeah that's
cool have you been to the plane venue
and yeah I have but now I'm waiting here
because the players came here to talk to
Russ yeah yeah you need to catch the
players right now yes so who am I hoping
to catch today
I'm hoping to catch I know youngsters
wow big plans yes I mean are you just
player yourself
yeah but I'm not a professional player
just casual playing yeah so uh why did
why did you decide to come here
[Music]
because I live in Warsaw and it's very
unique opportunity to meet the best
players
hello Julian it's really nice to meet
you here during this Championship can
you tell us your impressions how is it
going for you
um it's going good I'm I'm happy that
photosho can do that has like good forum
forum is to win with with great top
players and it's also nice that you know
there's this event in Warsaw where we
can see the best players in the world
and this is really good for chess I
think yeah have you been to the plane
Hall not yet only only here yes really
what are you doing here then I'm playing
Just tournament that is now like next to
the main tournament and we are playing
Blitz and it's also fun yeah how is it
going it's going okay first tournament
it was like Ninth Place now like first
win and we'll see what's what's later
yeah what are you looking for here
I am looking for some good memories with
food players maybe see them in the real
life and it would be a great experience
have you met anyone already no not yet
it's my first time it's the first time I
see and what they're looking for are you
looking uh for missing stuff Duda or
Magnus yeah I mean Magnus Magnus would
be fun but also Wesley so or like
Rapport they're all great players yeah
that's for sure thank you so much and
all the best of luck in the tournament
yes thank you foreign
[Music]